well our state anticipated an increase
in positive kovat 19 cases as more
businesses reopened and today Nevada
Health response along with the
Department of Health and Human Services
released the latest reopening response
plan
Kirsten joy starting us now with more
details on the enforcement part of that
plan Kirsten
denisa in order to make sure the spread
in the community is manageable until a
vaccine is created our state has begun a
targeted and aggressive strategy which
involves increased enforcement of
businesses not following the rules since
the beginning of June Nevada has
observed those increases - the number of
daily new Kovan 19 cases and
hospitalizations we've also learned
today the köppen 19 cases identified in
June have shifted to a younger age
demographic and a higher proportion of
cases are of Hispanic ethnic origin
members of the Department of business
and industry will be working with
businesses and chambers of commerce to
offer free face coverings OSHA has
started a new campaign to identify the
businesses that are not following social
distancing guidelines for Southern
Nevada to report a business not
following Kovan 19 directives which
includes social distancing and
mask-wearing call the number on the
lower portion of your screen that is
seven zero two four eight six nine zero
two zero on a conference call today
deputy administrator Julia peak have
this message for customers if you want
businesses to stay open and not be
subject to citation please wear your
face coverings upon entry you will be
helping to ensure their employees do not
get sick sick as well as other patrons
in their business the Department of
business and industry will make sure
there is enough staff to answer the call
in line to take these complaints and
conduct the follow up investigation of
these businesses now while many
businesses are following our governor's
directives about 85% the Nevada Gaming
Control Board says they've done more
than 7000 inspections of companies with
the gaming license and of those they've
opened 111 cases for not following the
rules Brian